♪
>> Shannon: JOINING US NOW
DR. MEHMET OZ ONE OF THE G.O.P.
CONTENDERS IN THE SENATE PRIMARY
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
COMING UP IN JUST DAYS.
DR. OZ, GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH
US.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE, SHANNON.
>> Shannon: THIS HAS GOTTEN TO
BE INCREDIBLY TIGHT RACE.
BRAND NEW POLLING GOT YOU AT THE
TOP OF THE PACK AT 22%.
McCORMICK 22%.
BARNETT 19%.
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WITHIN OUR
MARGIN OF ERROR.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
HEAR FROM YOUR CRITICS AND
RESPOND AS YOU ARE ALL NECK IN
NECK AT THIS POINT.
HERE ARE SOME JABS AS WHY YOU
AREN'T AS QUALIFIED AS THEY ARE.
>> THE REASON MEHMET KEEPS
TALKING ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT BECAUSE HE CAN'T RUN
ON HIS OWN POSITIONS AND HIS OWN
RECORDS.
WHAT'S TRUE IS THAT HE HAS FLIP
FLOPPED ON EVERY MAJOR ISSUE WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT IN THIS
CAMPAIGN.
>> WHEN THESE CARPET BAGGERS
LOSE, YOU WILL NEVER SEE THEM
AGAIN.
AND IF THEY SHOULD WIN, YOU WILL
NEVER SEE THEM AGAIN.
>> Shannon: IS FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT ENOUGH FOR
THE VOTER OF PENNSYLVANIA OR DO
YOU OFFER THEM MORE.
>> I OFFER LOTS MORE.
IT HELPS TREMENDOUSLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT
OPEN'S PEOPLES MINDS.
THEY CALL YOU BACK.
THEY TAKE MEETINGS WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR AN
CANDIDATE TO ARTICULATE WHY THEY
ARE THE BEST PERSON.
STRONGLY PRO-LIFE.
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
TED NUGENT ENDORSES ME.
ATTACKS OF $35 MILLION OF
NEGATIVE ADVERTISING PRIMARILY
FROM OUTSIDE PENNSYLVANIA.
BUT THE VOTERS HAVE FIGURED THAT
OUT.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP WARNED ME IF
YOU ARE AN OUTSIDER THE INSIDE
ESTABLISHMENT COME AFTER WITH
YOU EVERYTHING THEY HAVE GOT.
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STAND MY OWN
TWO FEET VERY PROUDLY AND LIVE
UP TO THE PROMISE OF MY
CAMPAIGN, WHICH IS TO IDENTIFY
WHY WASHINGTON IS GETTING IT
WRONG.
WHY ARE THEY NOT ALIGNING WITH
OUR VIEWS AND KNOWING THAT I CAN
GO TO WASHINGTON AND BE A
BULLDOG FOR OUR COMMONWEALTH
EVERYONE THAT I LOOKING FOR.
I HAVE BEEN DOING IT ON
TELEVISION AND IN MY OPERATING
ROOM FOR MANY YEARS.
>> Shannon: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN -- ONE OF
THOSE LEVELED AGAINST YOU IS
THAT YOU FLIP FLOPPED ON THE
ISSUE OF ABORTION.
HERE ARE YOUR TWO PRIMARY
OPPONENTS ON THAT.
>> I HAVE SEEN HIM ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS AND SPECIFICALLY AT
THE BREAKFAST CLUB SAYING THAT
MY LIFE WAS NOTHING MORE THAN A
A CORN WITH ELECTRICAL CURRENT.
I'M WONDERING IF THE GOOD DOCTOR
HAS NOW SINCE CHANGED HIS
POSITION ON THAT.
>> DID YOU GO BACK TO THAT
BREAKFAST CLUB INTERVIEW.
ATTACKS THE PRO-LIFE FOR PICKING
FIGHTS.
HE A ATTACKS STATES FOR PUTTING
IN PRO-LIFE LEGISLATION FOR
DISRUPTING BUSINESS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE
TO DEAL WITH, MEHMET.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A TRACK RECORD
THAT'S COMPLETELY OPPOSITE.
>> Shannon: THAT BREAKFAST CLUB
INTERVIEW 2019 YOU SAID YOU WERE
PRO-LIFE YOU WOULDN'T INTERFERE
WITH EVERYONE ELSE'S STUFF IS
THE QUOTE BECAUSE IT'S HARD
ENOUGH TO GET INTO LIFE AS IT
IS.
WHAT ABOUT THE CLIP THAT YOU
HAVE FLIP FLOPPED ON YOUR
POSITION.
>> CLEAR ON THAT INTERVIEW AND
ONLY ONE THEY KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THAT I WAS AGAINST THE LAW FROM
ALABAMA THAT WOULD BAN ABORTIONS
AND ALL EXCEPTIONS.
AND I AM OF THE BELIEF AS A
DOCTOR THAT IF THE LIFE OF THE
MOTHER IS TRULY AT RISK THAT
WOULD BE AN EXCEPTION THAT IS
EXCEPTIONAL.
I THINK KATHY BARNETT DON'T LIKE
THAT.
AS A HEART SURGEON I RESPECT THE
SANCTITY OF LIFE.
I TAKE CARE OF BABIES WHEN THEY
ARE FIRST BORN.
I KNOW THE SPECIALNESS OF THE
BABY AND NINE MONTHS EARLIER
STILL LIFE.
SHE RAISED QUESTIONS IN HER
CANDIDACY THAT SHE HAS REFUSED
TO ANSWER WHEN I'M ANSWERING
YOURS RIGHT NOW SUPPORTED BLACK
LIVES MATTER AND STATUE OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN PLACE OF
OTHER STRUCTURES THAT ARE SACRED
TO OUR COUNTRY.
ATTACKED THE FOUNDER OF OUR
COUNTRY GEORGE WASHINGTON AS
WELL AS ATTACKING PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> WHAT HE WAS IRONIC IS BIG
MONEY GROUPS NEVER TRUMP GROUPS
HAVE NOW COME INTO PENNSYLVANIA
WITH OUTSIDE MONEY AND THEY ARE
WRONGLY SUPPORTING KATHY BARNETT
AND PUTTING HER IN CONTENTION.
THIS IS A CANDIDATE WHO LOST BY
20 POINTS WHEN SHE RAN FOR
CONGRESS 18 MONTHS AGO.
SO SHE IS NOT GOING TO DO WELL
IN THE GENERAL ELECTION WHICH IS
WHY ENTREPRENEURSHIP OVER AND
OVER AGAIN EVEN TODAY PUT OUT A
NEW ANNOUNCEMENT I'M THE WON TO
SUPPORT BECAUSE I CAN WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED AS
REPUBLICANS ANOTHER SENATOR TO
TAKE THE PLACE OF THE CURRENT
RETIRING SENATOR IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
IF YOU WANT THAT YOU SHOULD VOTE
FOR DR. OZ WHICH I THINK IS WHY
I'M STILL LEADING IN THE POLLS.
>> Shannon: THEY ARE TIGHT.
WITHIN THE MARGIN OFFER.
SHE IS SURGING.
I WILL SPEAK WITH HER IN A
COUPLE OF DAYS AND ASK HER THOSE
QUESTIONS BUBBLIN